one two three
frank you should be good you're going to
hit live
if anything i have it in my car yeah i
mean
some of these guys are veterans they
need to stretch their knees
i said veteran i didn't use the other
one
use this one
it's gonna get in the way
james
uh
[Music]
everybody i know it's tight but we gotta
accommodate everybody guys everyone
audio understand that but we gotta
accommodate everybody everyone's got
sound
on the left everyone's got sound
you guys here one two three
and everyone here
thumbs up yeah
come over here
audio oreo everyone's good
all right
audio check
everyone
you guys here
so mike's on this side new shelf are you
here
all
back up right
strength
okay
yes
guys
[Music]
nice
[Music]
absolutely
i'm crazy
yes
it's just as good as yours
all right everyone this is going to be a
two minute warning all right
all right we're gonna do a quick sound
check one more time can i see my left
how am i on my left
left hand side
left hand side how
abc how we doing abc can you hear me
sound check abc
fox news fox news
fox 5 news nation
pix11 you have me
new york one you have me
associated press you have me
wcvx880 can you hear me
cbs
10 10 wins
yeah all right thank you everybody
oh
over here
[Music]
you don't want to take it off
all right
all right
hello
here we go
oh
[Music]
thank you thanks so much
[Music]
oh
guys we're gonna do one more quick sound
check i just want to make sure that
we're okay fox news give me your hands
up all right
you gotta hurry up we're gonna go
we're going in a minute
all right white fox news does that thing
give me abc can you hear me
news nation
i'm trying fox5
pix11
new york one
frank 7
associated press cbs80
four
cbs
television
1010
news 12.
univision
cnn
all right thank you everybody
chris
you can't
that guy right there you can't leave
that microphone like that
who's this this
he's running over there is
[Music]
go back right now
is
we're going to start right now
fox news fox news you got me you're
better all right thank you you're
welcome
hello
guys will be starting momentarily
there's no more all the everybody has no
authority to the mics everybody's good
right
all right thank you everybody i
appreciate it
is
[Music]
you want to go higher
good
i like it
thank you very
thank
much
uh
oh
oh
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i know the fight
bye
all right a little change guys it could
be another 5 10 minutes
where's channel 7 abc
abc do you have audio give me a thumbs
up if you have audio
abc
you guys sit down
[Music]
thank you
very much
yes
job
all right
yes
say
[Music]
uh
[Laughter]
legendary
um
he's still dead
uh
okay
but there are sometimes officers
patrolling stations subway stations and
patrolling the cars
we also believe
random
new york city mayor eric adams has
promised to make subway crime a top
priority
deploying teams
like this
[Music]
subway but new york city mayor eric
adams
um
[Music]
across the city
um
including the n and the r trains where
this incident took place
i can't say that someone who takes the
subway almost every day i do see
a good number
[Music]
even doing random bag checks
well gina anyone can walk right onto the
subway but new york city mayor eric
adams has said tackling subway crime is
one of his top priorities deploying
teams to various subway stations across
the city and some target subway lines
including the n and the r trains which
is where this incident unfolded and as
someone who takes the subway every day i
can tell you that we do often see
officers patrolling the stations and the
cars sometimes even doing random back
checks
we'll do the same thing for this except
for this one i have a question
better
oh my god that dog is so cute
adam geary
bloomberg's bloomberg's livestream on
twitter
the invite
so you should probably set up a new one
it's gina
okay
i'm not gonna do their stick out because
they're asking me a question
hey it's
well gina anyone can walk right on to
the subway but new york city mayor eric
adams has vowed to make subway crime a
top priority he has deployed teams to
various subway stations to deploy teams
to various subway stations across the
city uh and also
subway lines including the n and the r
trains which is the trains that were
involved in this incident
i can't say someone who takes the
[Music]
okay
[Music]
deputy mayor
first step
okay
we'll outline the events as we know them
laura cavanaugh the first deputy
commissioner
later this
afternoon where we'll be able to update
that and then i just want to keep it
first deputy mayor lorraine grillo
guys very special thank you thank you
john
agencies
if
we're not in the special resources
lisa underscore lewis i'm wis intuitive.
to speak to you and give you an update
on the events
thank you
good afternoon
we're here to update new yorkers about
an active shooting incident that took
place this morning inside the 36th
street subway station on the n line
i want to begin by assuring the public
that there are currently no known
explosive devices on our subway trains
and this is not being investigated as an
act of terrorism at this time
we can also report that although this
was a violent incident reportedly we
have no one with life-threatening
injuries as a result of this case this
investigation is only hours old so
please note this information is subject
to change
just before 8 24 this morning as the
manhattan-bound end train waited to
enter the 36th street station an
individual on that train donned what
appeared to be a gas mask
he then took a canister out of his bag
and opened it
the train at that time began to fill
with smoke
he then opened fire striking multiple
people on the subway
and in the platform
again
we will describe him as an individual he
is being reported as a male black
approximately five feet five inches tall
with a heavy build
he was wearing a green construction type
vest and a hooded sweatshirt the color
is gray
at this time we are working with our
federal partners where we are asking for
the public's help anyone with
information videos or photographs no
matter how insignificant they think it
may be is encouraged to call crime
stoppers at 800 577 tips all calls are
strictly confidential
i'd like to turn it over to the fdny to
give information about the victims
oh i'm sorry
i apologize the governor would like to
speak now governor hope my apologies
that's right
uh good afternoon
this morning
ordinary new yorkers woke up
in anticipation of a
relatively normal day
they've left their homes
and moved to school
and moved their jobs
into a normal day as i mentioned
that sense of tranquility and normalness
was disrupted brutally disrupted
by an individual
so cold-hearted
and when they do this
about the individuals that they
assaulted
as they simply went about their daily
lives this individual is
this person is dangerous
they're asking you to
be very vigilant and alert
you'll get more reports on specificity
as the day goes on
this is an active shooter situation
right now in the city of new york i just
got off the phone with the mayor he's
recovering well he is monitoring he's
actively engaged in this situation i
wanted to let you know
that the people of the entire state of
new york stand with the people of the
city this community and we say no more
no more mass shootings
no more disrupting lives
creating heartbreak for people
trying to live their lives
[Music]
the loss of a teenage girl okay and
skype is a 17 year old
it has to stop doom i'm committing the
full resources of our state i i find
this search about this this is standing
that is seizing our city because
okay it's been a long hard two years
that's what we create
that sense
stability okay and normalcy and this is
what the mayor and i are going to
continue to work toward and i thank the
partners and you can bring me correct
people the mta the first ones who had
the sense the drivers of the train to
leave the station to make sure no more
victims could be hurt
nypd
fdny
state police
everyone involved in this has one
purpose
it has to stop the insanity of these
crimes
you'll hear now
from our fire department i want to thank
them for being there to help us accuse a
volatile situation
but we'll be giving continued reports as
this day unfolds
again
everyone involved in it has one purpose
that has to stop the insanity of these
crimes together as new yorkers united in
economic purposes to say no more our
department
reports of gunshot victims in the subway
[Music]
um
with all of the tech issues um i'm going
to give them a call if that's all right
with you first of all
we've done so much to
protect us and okay thank you
immediately to recover from this
situation and i also need to acknowledge
the mta workers who had were at the
foresight to
immediately move a train that was on the
platform the r train out of the station
so it could carry people to safety that
was that was smart thinking right now uh
b service is
suspended w service is suspended the d
and the n and the r are running with
suspensions and some shuttle buses
and
folks should check the website for
latest obviously it's a disruptive
uh day
but a lot of the system is in fact
running i just want to say one thing on
a personal note which is on 9 11 i stood
on 4th avenue and watch people new
yorkers come back from that tragedy and
i thought i watched new yorkers help
each other and scored all right and then
same thing with klcd that was the same
thing we saw in the class oh they had to
cancel
new yorkers in a difficult situation an
emergency helping each other back to the
subway
riders are every day they're showing
in the subway which is our public space
and new yorkers
is
um
uh
okay
[Music]
like two or three minutes each yeah
um
going through
okay
is
[Music]
i'm more worried about either older
people
girlfriend's mother or my mother or
somebody you know other people than
myself
um
street park slope and 36 and then down
to bay ridge particularly not really
security
particularly
like my mother
you know she was she would bring it up
so
there's more police when the kids get
out of school
um
and it was of a level the magnitude was
clear from how they were not looking
back not lingering just trying to get
away and some people were incapacitated
and needed help tell me what you saw
what you heard what were the people
doing when they were getting off
um they were running uh down to like
high streets took it out and walked the
avenue or go down the avenue and then
there were people who were unable to do
so and were shouting for help
and uh there was a lot of confusion i
think there were some people didn't know
which way to go so there were some
people who were indecisive
you know they should head
what was going through your mind
i've been a shooting
and maybe you know
a
shooting that is a massive shooting
um
i had no idea i think the thing that
kind of really struck me was when i
found out that there were undetonated
devices possibly
um
and
yeah no i just
i didn't think very much about it
because i was observing everything
digest and consider well what is this
like it's just 36th street station
they've been like isolated incidents you
know every once in a while my life but
never anything like where there's a
major attack and were people yelling out
what is that well people have a lot of
people have facebook
so you couldn't hear and then a lot of
people weren't speaking english
so but it was more the the tone
and their inability to move they were
clearly asking for help and other people
calling and screaming for the police did
you see any people that were injured
yeah would you describe them
well it was somebody whose leg looked
deformed like broken i didn't see you
know i saw what looked like blood but i
wasn't sure
um but they were clearly um
seriously injured
and i didn't see anybody who looked
critically injured but it was like um
gunshot wound obviously
now city-wide or even broader punt for
the individual she's responsible for
this
again
students may break out here and there
um one person you know rob a store
but
again later in the afternoon
you still have it in your background